we begin the day with what is looking
more and more like the final fall of
Aleppo the regime of Bashar al-assad
Russia Iran and their affiliated militia
are the ones responsible for what the UN
called a complete meltdown of humanity
the battle for Aleppo is over are you
truly incapable of shame is there
literally nothing that can shame you
Aleppo has fallen the city formerly the
most populous place in Syria was the
site of a major battle between Bashar
al-assad government and rebel forces the
rebels controlled the eastern half of
the city and Assad the West
the story of Syria's Civil War is a
story of flip-flops early on it looked
like the Assad regime was finished
intervention by Iran and support by
Russia helped prop them up then the
rebels backed by Saudi Arabia and Qatar
and several other sides turned the tides
and this happened a number of different
times inside the conflict September 2015
was a turning point in the Syrian civil
war
that's when Russia intervened directly
for the first time Russian airstrikes
began pounding rebels under the cover
and hitting Isis Russian airstrikes
played a decisive role and allowing
Assad to encircle Aleppo the bombardment
made it very difficult for rebels to
operate freely allowing Assad to move
towards Aleppo and eventually encircle
the city a siege is a military tactic
where forces on one side surround the
other side including any civilians
trapped in there and denies supplies
from entering the city there was a grim
logic to imposing a siege on Aleppo if
you deny rebels food and medicine
eventually they lose the physical and
mental capability to fight Assad's
vicious siege worked as intended
the rebels collapsed allowing Assad
forces with Iranian and Russian backing
to stream into eastern Aleppo almost
immediately reports of massacres started
filtering out civilians being killed on
the streets of women committing suicide
to avoid being raped by Assad's forces
it's hard to know how many were killed
in this initial purge we do now shortly
after the siege was broken an evacuation
agreement was struck allowing again an
unknown number of civilians to escape
into other territory mostly to the city
of hit liebe stone rebel ends the United
States had the military power to break
the siege of Aleppo and prevent the city
from falling but doing so would have
been extremely dangerous
for one thing the United States would
have needed to have coordinated with
rebels on the ground some of whom were
extremists for another it would have
mean that American planes would have
been flying in hostile airspace with
Russian planes if the United States were
to engage Russian planes that would mean
a direct exchange of fire between two
nuclear-armed powers a risk that very
few in Washington were willing to take
third even if the US had temporarily
broken the siege of Aleppo and prevented
it from falling it would have required a
tremendous and open-ended commitment to
prevent Assad from simply reimposing the
siege after Americans left whether or
not you think an American intervention
would have been worth the risks there's
no way to save a lepton now the city has
fallen and Assad's troops have gone in
and committed untold atrocities with who
knows how many more left to go the
rebels have been dealt a devastating
blow when it's not clear they can
recover from this victory first sod has
been achieved with the support of two
major international powers Russia and
Iran and it has involved atrocities that
are supposed to be prevented under
international law they fought horrific
aliy and they won that's the lesson of
Aleppo